il ya malgré tout des endroits dans
l'est du québec où les avis d'ébullition
vous savez c'est une pratique courante
en particulier pour trois municipalités
qui elle doit faire bouillir leur eau
depuis 12 ans en fait depuis la tragédie
de l'eau contaminée de walkerton en
ontario qui a fait seulement jean
françois deschênes à la martre en
gaspésie c'est la mairesse déteste l'eau
de sa municipalité
le résultat elle le connaît nasrullah y
voir des coliformes fécaux
ils vont avoir des coliformes totaux
piccoli c'est pas la bactérie e coli et
la responsable de la tragédie de
walkerton sept personnes sont mortes
après avoir bu l'eau contaminée à
l'époque québec inspectent sitôt 2400
réseau d'aqueduc 90 réseaux devait être
mise aux normes le gouvernement donnait
20 jours pour trouver une solution
depuis environ six ans résidant de la
martre en gaspésie dans une teinte à
rebours et de rivière pentecôte sur la
côte nord doivent toujours faire
bouillir leur eau pour jocelyne cléry la
patience a ses limites et pour les gens
qui vivent ici quand gary n'a pas lieu
douche froide qu'elle louait tout moi il
ya certaines périodes emprunte un
terrible ça tacle un moment donné locaux
faudrait que ça aboutisse à un moment
donné
dans chacun des cas il existe une
solution mais le problème c'est l'argent
à la martre québec offre de payer 85 %
des 6 millions de dollars que coûterait
le nouveau réseau d'aqueduc une
augmentation de taxes beaucoup trop
importante pour la soixantaine de
propriétaires touchés ce que je veux
c'est de l'eau pour moi au village pour
les gens d'ici pour la santé des gens
disent enfin comment voulez vous
développer quelque chose dans la
municipalité quand qu'on n'a pas le
service essentiel l'eau avec un moment
donné au lieu d'un vice certainement
dans des villes look en laisse un petit
peu de côté qui nous en donne équipe et
nous autres ça fait du bien c'est ce que
j'ai dit la municipalité espère toujours
une entente avec le gouvernement qui
d'ailleurs n'a pas voulu commenter
aujourd'hui jean-françois des chaînes
radio canada la martre en gaspésie